have you seen the liquid death water
company yeah this company is valued at
700 million dollars they literally sell
water in a can and yes it's in this like
tall boy can and yes it's got like the
over-the-top death metal aesthetic but
it's just water I think what this shows
us is that liquid death understands how
human brains work we think we're like
rational people who go out and like buy
things because they're useful to us like
we're gonna go buy water because we need
water that's not what's happening here
they're nakedly showing just how
powerful branding is because they're
getting people to buy a product that is
objectively worthless because it looks
kind of cool and edgy and weird and
counterculture liquid death is about
signaling to others and maybe yourself a
little bit that you are
anti-establishment and that's freaking
brilliant whoever's in charge of the
marketing over at liquid death deserves
an A plus but now after thinking about
this it's like I can't stop thinking of
all the other things that I purchase in
my life that aren't about the product
but are about what buying the product
says about me